[Music]
no doubt you're sending chaos in the
streets
we must make an example our France will
fall
what would you do if this assignment of
defense was transferred to you
[Applause]
I promise you go and successes
everyone around
what does this costing me level this is
my uniform
I let the French victory at too long
what is your name Napoleon
the course of my life has changed
Napoleon
[Applause]
I'm destined for greatness
like I was in power will only see me as
a sword
I suggest you take the throne as a king
shall we vote
this learning has held the world of
Hostage with his egotism and his lack of
simple good manners
I'm great
that is nothing without me
of Europe is United forces against me
what's the outcome of this you don't
succeed
Your Majesty we are discovered good
first to admit when I make a mistake
I simply never do
foreign